on en parle tout de suite avec vous jean
vincent brisset vous êtes chercheur
associé à l'iris bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct ce matin sur rtl
france donc on voit ces mesures et
stratégies 0 qu'ovide en chine alors que
le pays a quand même on a l'impression
plutôt bien géré
la situation sanitaire comment vous vous
expliquer justement ce confinement d'une
ville intiale 13 millions d'habitants là
je crois qu'on est au bout de la logique
0 qu'ovide parce que comme com vient
d'être dit 50 cas pour 13 millions
d'habitants en une journée ça serait
merveilleux si on avait ça dans un pays
européen et en chine c'est considéré
comme une catastrophe parce que de la
saint jean n'a pas fonctionné
complètement comme il l'aurait voulu
parce que zéro co vite ça veut dire
tester mais ça veut dire aussi tracé ça
veut dire isolé donc on passe on passe
très brutalement à l'isolation pour
aller jusqu'au bout de cette logique bon
c'est vrai il ya les jo d'hiver à de
pékin qui débute en février mais est ce
que vous croyez que finalement il ya un
traumatisme en chine puisque c'est de là
qu'est partie la pandémie est donc une
oui je pense le peuple chinois soient
conscients et soient traumatisés par le
fait que ça a pu partir de chez lui le
peuple chinois et traumatisés parce que
ce qui se passe et les présenter comme
très grave et il change complètement ses
habitudes de vie les fantômes blanc qui
vaccinent qui nettoie qui quittent et
qui prennent à température et autres
reviennent dans leurs vies reviennent
dans leur vie de manière extrêmement
intrusive ce qui est quand même vraiment
un problème mais c'est un choix du
gouvernement face à des choses qui
avancent et phase peut-être à des
problèmes parce que le vaccin développé
par la chine n'a peut-être pas
l'efficacité nécessaire et face à un
micro peut-être que ce sera encore pire
alors justement comment réagir la
population chinoise parce qu'on voit des
vagues de contestations un peu partout
dans le monde on sait qu'en chine les
videmment le pouvoir à pékin est quand
même à
autoritaire d'une certaine façon dont on
sait que pour la population ce n'était
pas évident de d'exprimer aussi son
mécontentement
alors il ya deux choses en chine ya
d'abord le fait que effectivement on est
dans un vase un pays extrêmement
autoritaire avec des sanctions brutale
et violente mais aussi le fait dans la
civilisation chinoise le groupe passe
avant l'individu et que c'est
relativement normalement acceptez donc
on a quelque chose qui est un but sinon
on peut appeler ça du civisme mais une
acceptation de toutes les contraintes au
profit du groupe des contraintes sur
l'individu qui arrive normalement
alors sur les jo d'hiver de pékin qui
doivent débuter en février là aussi du
côté des autorités il ya une pression
c'est une n'est pas question de renoncer
à l'organisation des cjo
bien entendu le saas est une catastrophe
sur le plan de l'image pour la chine de
renoncer à ces jo il ya déjà des
boycotts d'autorité enfin y'a pas de
boycott de sportifs pour le moment à ma
connaissance mais il ya déjà des
autorités de deux pays qui aurait dû
envoyer des gouvernants pour assister à
ces jo qui ne qui ne vont pas y aller si
le relais si le boycott est remplacée
par une absence pour des raisons
sanitaires ou pire encore par une
annulation des jo une image pour la
chine le coup en matière d'image est
extrêmement grave alors sur le la
campagne vaccinale
où en est-on en chine exactement
alors il semblerait que à toute
vaccination extrêmement important là
aussi la chine est est capable de
mobiliser une industrie pour fabriquer
des vaccins et de mobiliser
sa population pourrait être vaccinés
donc ce n'est pas étonnant que qu'elle
réussit à avoir c'est taux de
vaccination est aussi ce taux de tests
qui commence par des prises de
température
dix vies duels et les images que vous
montrez en ce moment montrent le lac
cette quantité de tests qui étaient
acceptées qui est normal tous les jours
et tout ça s'est appuyé sur ce système
de de civisme en fin de 2 points de
civisme les gens qui ne sont pas
vaccinés qui ne sont pas testés qui ne
sont pas quand ceux qui n'acceptent pas
confinement sont immédiatement exclu sur
le plan social et dans les situations
épouvantables alors y'a de la menace
omicron partout dans le monde quels sont
vos informations à ce niveau s'agissant
précisément de la chine et par ailleurs
est-ce que vous avez des informations
sur l'efficacité du vaccin chinois
sinopharm
sur la valeur de micro moment on a
entendu dire qu'il y aura eu un cas en
chine là aussi les informations données
par les officiels donnés par la chine
c'est assez difficile à décrypter on
sait pas exactement ce qu'il en est sur
l'efficacité du vaccin par contre je
pense que le fait que ce vaccin n'est
pas été acceptée par l'union européenne
ou par par les états unis peuvent quand
même quelque part qu il ya des problèmes
avec ce vaccin et les chiffres qu'on a
je suis pas du tout un spécialiste de ça
mais les chiffres qu'on assemble prouver
qu effectivement face aux variants delta
déjà le vaccin sinovac tu n'as pas
vraiment l'efficacité je veux avoir un
frère ou un modern art
merci beaucoup à vous jean vincent
brisset d'avoir répondu à nos questions
en direct je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé à l'iris